[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es eine ganz schnelle
geburtstagstorte und ganz viele
schnellbach tipps es ist ja oft so dass
noch auspacken will man hat aber nur
ganz wenig zeit das heißt wie kann man
am schnellsten backen diese tipps habe
ich in diesem video jetzt für euch und
die torte wird richtig cooles wird eine
konfetti torte ihr könnt ihr natürlich
auch abwandeln ich mache jetzt hier
einen basis tykwer ihr könnt auch eine
schokotorte draus machen oder jeden
anderen geschmack mit reinbringen den
ihr möchtet ich mache jetzt meinen
mantel rührteig den kennt ihr auch
bereits aus meinen basics und da ist es
immer ganz gut wenn die eier zimmer warm
sind wenn ihr aber ganz spontan backt
sind die eier meist nichts immer warum
sondern im kühlschrank zumindest bei uns
und dann macht er ist einfach so dass
ihr die eier im ganzen in warmes wasser
legt nicht in kochendes so habt ihr
nämlich gekochte eier und dann werden
sie ganz schnell zimmer war und so
lassen sie sich auch viel viel schneller
voluminös aufschlagen so könnt ihr im
übrigen auch ganz gut erkennen ob die
eier noch frisch sind oder ob sie alt
sind denn alte eier schwimmen an der
wasseroberfläche was auch in schnellbach
tipp ist finde ich zumindest die zutaten
vorher einmal alle ganz kurz abbiegen
dass er nicht während dem backen noch
mal rum burschen müsst und einfach noch
was suchen müsst ich zeige euch mal kurz
die zutaten für den teig für den teig
verwende ich sechs eier eine prise salz
300 gramm zucker etwas vanille extrakt
und bittermandel extrakt jeweils 300
gramm butter milch und sonnenblumenöl
450 gramm mehl ein päckchen backpulver
200 gramm gemahlene mandeln und etwas
konfetti streusel und es geht jetzt auch
direkt los die eier kommen jetzt in die
rührschüssel gemeinsam mit dem salz und
zucker
und da werden sie jetzt für 4 bis 5
minuten schaumig verrührt oder ganz
cremig und in der zeit werde ich schon
mal meine back ringe bereitstellen
[Musik]
es gebe ich hier die zwei flüssigkeiten
rein also butter milch und öl dann etwas
vanille extrakt und wie tamandl aroma
hier würde ich jetzt kurz runter und
kann jetzt auch schon mal die trockenen
zutaten 7 also das mehl mit dem
backpulver
da kommen jetzt auch noch die gemahlenen
mandeln mit rein
die zutaten werde ich jetzt einfach nur
kurz einrühren könnte auch mit der
küchenmaschine machen aber nur auf
niedriger stufe wird sich alles
verbunden hat und dann noch die kunden
für die streusel guckt mal so schön die
aussehen sind natürlich erstmal
zugesprochen hatte und damit der jetzt
superschnell backt werde ich ihnen jetzt
in vier tortenring gegeben
ihr könnt entweder nur zwei nehmen dann
ist aber die backzeit etwas länger oder
nimmt vier und backt bei heißluft also
in auf zwei unterschiedlichen ebenen
die habe ich jetzt bereits eingeschlagen
dann der teig einfach etwas flüssiger
rateike ist jetzt schön aufteilen
jetzt werden sie gleichzeitig bei
heißluft gebacken oder wenn ihr nur in 2
back ringen packt dann gerne auch bei
ober unterhitze aber dann verlängert
sich auf jeden fall die backzeit die
kuren böden sind gebacken und nach dem
backen zu sehen wir direkt vom blech
herunter
das backpapier oder debug folie las ich
dann aber noch dran und setze sie direkt
auf eine abkühlung gitter so kommt
gleich luft von unten dran
sie können schneller ab und danach
stelle ich sie immer kurz ins
gefrierfach so sind sie nämlich bereit
zum befüllen für die cremes verwendet
400 gramm frischkäse etwas zitrone
passte 500 gramm quark 80 gramm
puderzucker 500 gramm sahne und etwas an
apache spüre jetzt zuerst in frischkäse
mit dem quark in der schüssel stadt
frischkäse könnt ihr hier auch
mascarpone zum beispiel nehmen oder
einfach etwas merkt
quark noch dazu und für den geschmack
etwas zitronen passte
und wenn man nur die zitronenschale
braucht das aroma ist echt praktisch
hatte passte zu nehmen weil man dann die
zitronen nicht abschreiben muss und die
daneben auch länger haltbar bleibt oder
ihr könnt die zitronen einfach abreiben
einfrieren und dann habt ihr immer was
auf vorrat
dann kommt die cd puderzucker dazu alles
kurz berühren
jetzt geht's ans füllen da nehme ich
jetzt zuerst einmal einen tortenboden
und somit vier back ringen spart ihr
euch natürlich auch das zuschneiden ihr
könnt sie nochmal zu schneiden dann habt
ihr ach mist aber nicht so ich werde
jetzt noch etwas fruchtiges mit
reinbringen dann nehme ich jetzt ne
ballade das selbstgemachte das ist
einfach eine frucht mischung gewesen aus
kirschen erdbeeren himbeeren
da hatte ich alle reste mitgekocht die
ich noch so hatte aus dem garten jetzt
hier verstreichen
kommt jetzt die creme drauf
selbst hier noch einen tortenring außen
rum dann ist das füllen etwas einfacher
und jetzt die creme schön verstreichen
und so füllt ihr dann die gesamte torte
und etwas creme wir dann noch übrig
bleiben die brauche ich doch noch für
die deko
also wenn euch die höhe erreicht könnt
ihr nur zwei bilden button
so ständig die torte jetzt in den
kühlschrank entweder für eine stunde
kühlschrank oder für eine halbe stunde
ins gefrierfach und dann entferne ich
den tortenring und streich mit der
übrigen kredite schon ein
so sieht die torte jetzt aus richtig
schön durch gekühlt jetzt kann ich sie
komplett mit der creme bestreichen
ich mache da immer erst eine dünne
schicht so werden die krümel gebunden
und hat dann meistens eine zweite
schüssel habe ich dann einfach die creme
mit den krümeln abstreifen kann und dann
geht schon an die oberfläche und alles
geht
zum schluss trage ich dann immer noch
etwas creme an den rand auf zieht damit
der teig karte ab dann ist ja auch schön
glatt und hier oben geht dann mit der
winkel palette dran und c von außen hier
in die mitte und je nachdem was für eine
deko ihr machen wollte musste entweder
perfekt glatt sein oder eben nicht ganz
so perfekt dass entscheidet ihr dann an
welchem punkt ihr darauf hört
so lasse ich jetzt die torte es ist im
übrigen immer einfacher buttercremetorte
glatt zu streichen denn butter wird ja
in der creme auch wieder richtig schön
fest und wird dennoch an der torte hat
das heißt mit quark cremes oder
frischkäse krebs ist das bisschen
schwieriger aber die schmecken halt
generell so ein bisschen leichter
deswegen habe ich jetzt eine frischkäse
quark rehm gewählt ich schon dass die
torte noch mal kurz in den kühlschrank
ich habe hier noch ein bisschen rest
creme die reicht mir allerdings nicht
aus das heißt ich werde noch ein
bisschen was aufschlagen müssen damit
ich die torte gleich fertigte gering und
die stelle ich jetzt einfach kurz ins
gefrierfach damit sie eben auch
schneller festwirt und die pflege die
fordert weiterhin noch den grübel hier
einfach noch mal 200 gramm sahne etwas
sonderbar und blaue lebensmittel
verpasste so kann ich die creme ein
bisschen einfärben und bekomme einfach
noch mal einen schönen besonderen effekt
hin
rim habe ich jetzt in einen spritzbeutel
gefüllt mit großer stern thüle und das
ist eine fein gezeigte stelle übrigens
wenig diesen spritzbeutel ständer
benutze und den sprit model ein fühle
dann klicke ich und nimmer die spitze ab
und legt den beutel so rein so dass
einfach unten nichts heraus druck
und dann kann man es zu drehen und die
creme praktisch hochdrücken perfekt und
dann lege ich es immer so um rein ganz
abstellen ohne dass sich saubere in der
küche habe jetzt setzt sich die torte
kreuzung
jetzt setzt sich hier oben die tupfen
drauf immer zuerst die gegenüberliegende
seite dann das kreuz
so habe ich die torte schon mal
eingeteilt und dann sitze ich hier
zwischendrin noch die punkte
jetzt habe ich hier einfach ein blech
drum dargestellt damit die streusel
bahrain fallen können und jetzt nämlich
die konfetti streusel und drückte mit
der hand an den rand der torte
so wäre die torte jetzt schon fertig
finde ich wenn man da jetzt kerzen drauf
steigt oder wunderkerzen dann ist es
schon eine richtig schöne
geburtstagstorte aber ich habe noch
einen richtig coolen schnellen deko tipp
für euch und den zeige ich euch jetzt
dafür werde ich jetzt 100 gramm weiße
kuvertüre erst noch schmelzen und
temperieren das heißt zuerst einmal zwei
drittel davon über dem warmen wasserbad
erwärmen dann herr unternehmen und das
restliche drittel unterrühren
so hat die kuvertüre die perfekte
temperatur und so kann ich sie
weiterverwenden
jetzt ist die kuvertüre bereit und ich
für sie jetzt in einen gefrierbeutel ein
den stelle ich einfach in so ein glas so
kann ich ihn besser bevor dann die kurve
rein
und er mich jetzt bereits eine vorlage
gezeichnet und zwar mache ich jetzt
einfach die zahl 7
so könnt ihr schönen geburtstagszahlen
machen oder auch buchstaben
jetzt habe ich hier in la folie drin und
kann jetzt einfach mit hilfe dieses
gefrierbeutel gefahr schön aufschreiben
herzchen machen
und jetzt gebe ich hier noch streusel
drauf unterzucker streusel und kann so
die farbe ändern und natürlich auch ein
bisschen struktur einbringen entweder
nehmen die jetzt bunt oder einfarbig auf
jeden fall sollten es kleine perlen sein
damit das ganze auch schön
flächendeckend wird jetzt ein bisschen
überschuss kann ich jetzt schon mal weg
nehmen ganz vorsichtig
jetzt kann ich es ganz sicher so in form
bringen und stelle dann das ganze in den
kühlschrank ist die zahl festwirt und
macht dann auf der rückseite und da
kommt dann auch das stück spies rein
damit ich es eben auch schön in die
tasche stecken kann
die kuvertüre weit im kühlschrank jetzt
kann ich die zahlen ganz vorsichtig ab
und jetzt komme ich mir darum die
rückseite da mache ich genau das gleiche
das heißt schokolade auftragen hier
kommt einfach jetzt nur noch der schlick
spies rein damit ich die zahl eben auch
auf der torte befestigen kann
den erhöht jetzt hier ein bisschen so
dass er schön gerade auflegt
da hier noch ein bisschen andrücken kurz
warten bis das fest wird am besten im
kühlschrank und da kann ich hier auch
den überschuss einfach wegschicken und
hier bin ich jetzt etwas vorsichtiger
denn ich möchte ja dass der stab jetzt
auch schön gerade darin trocknet
david die torte probieren die sieben war
mit im endeffekt doch bis hin zu groß
die technik ist zwar ganz cool aber das
nächste mal am besten vorher ausmessen
deswegen haben wir jetzt auch nicht auf
die torte gesetzt so du darfst jetzt
probieren
du musst nicht in zeitlupe essen kannst
in echtzeit und das schmeckt der sehr
schokolade probier mal die torte die für
einfache land die kriegt sogar der
parteien
[Musik]
aus
ich glaube sie schmeckt lecker
warum ist er draußen war sehr bunt ist
das weit kommt
[Musik]
und so dem konto
also ich glaube auch dass es ein
ziemlich leckere torte und vor allem
sehr saftig und ihr könnt sie wirklich
abwandeln soll werden möchte ist eine
richtig schnelle geburtstagstorte die
auch wieder hinbekommt das rezept findet
ihr auf cds - blog.de der machart darfst
ja auch gleich probieren und falls sie
noch wieder wünsche dann schreibt sie
gerne in die kommentare
bis zum nächsten mal
[Applaus]
[Musik]
gefällt ihr die farbe
ist halt erst das konfetti nico an der
farbe
[Musik]
und davor mal ausprobieren
folgen
[Musik]